événement social à peugeot à poissy un
cariste intérimaire est monté sur le
toit du bâtiment à 15 mètres de haut cet
après midi il avait appris à la veille
par la direction qu'il ne pourrais plus
travailler chez peugeot il est resté
deux heures sur le toit avant de
redescendre à être pris en charge par le
samu
le raid avait été appelé avant de
finalement retenir son intervention
l'entreprise aurait garanti à se
salarier six semaines de travail
supplémentaires on va écouter tout de
suite le témoignage de quelques-uns des
salariés du groupe peugeot psa au micro
de la rédaction au micro de jonathan
vilma non récurrents du tueur météo de
pessah de psa on est la suppression de
onze mille deux cent cinquante postes
donc il y a que 100 de l'association
5,705 poste donc 705 consignes lancées
donc les salariés la d re passe au plomb
donc la direction il fait tout pour
qu'il parte de même bien donc comme il
trouve pas des volontaires donc la diac
sont ils pas ça il faut il faire
moi personnellement j'ai deux prisons de
la république à plusieurs reprises et le
milieu de travail mais voilà ils disent
qu'on va faire quelque chose mais
jusqu'à maintenant ils n'ont rien fait
et dans ce cas précis c'est comme la
question des charges de travail qui
posait et de la précarité inscrits aux
gars c'est quand même un intérimaire et
père de famille il a deux enfants
on lui dit tu mettras plus et puis à psa
voir que ça fait ça fait déjà des années
qui tourne d'une usine à autre et que si
l'on gagne pas forcément qui peut être
répond qu il y a eu des pressions
terribles sur lui au niveau charge de
travail il ya eu des propos racistes qui
ont été tenus envers cette personne
et donc voilà arrivés à un moment ils
pouvaient plus tenir et pour simple
réponse les rues l'encadrement général
ont rien trouvé de mieux que d'informer
la boîte d'intérim pour justement qu'il
ne puisse plus travailler dans la région
il soit grillé au niveau de psa au
niveau de la région donc arrivé à un
moment
effectivement le salarié on a voulu
mettre fin à ses jours